[Music]
it began an endgame and it was tease
that in one division in loki there was
really no other theme and it will be the
center of attention in doctor strange
too we're talking about the multiverse
the official title is doctor strange and
the multiverse of madness for a reason
it is set to hit theaters in march of
next year and in the meantime there are
already quite a few rumors and facts
surrounding the cast and the plot in
order to be well prepared and to bridge
the time until the first official
trailer we have summarized everything
you need to know about the movie in this
video
everything important that happened
before will be discussed again in this
part now
if you want to avoid being spoiled for
one division or end game you should
quickly skip ahead to the next section
the movie of course picks up after the
events of doctor strange 1 and game and
1 division dr steven strange has
defeated the evil cassilius and domamu
became keeper of the time stone and now
must protect earth from evil magical
forces along with the avengers he fights
thanos and is ultimately the one who
tells iron man that there is only one
possible way for everyone to be saved he
also helped thor find his father odin in
thor ragnarok moreover he is expected to
get a role in spider-man no way home
whether this takes place before or after
multiverse of madness is not yet a
hundred percent certain since this movie
is also yet to be released in theaters
incidentally we have already made a
video for this one which you can access
by simply clicking on the link in the
video description below wanda in turn
has created her own reality after
defeating thanos in which vision is
still alive and they even have children
in the end she becomes the infamous
scarlet witch whether this is good or
bad is something we will come back to
later
let's move on to the cast as we will not
only see familiar faces again first
pictures from the set have also shown us
new characters that we will meet in the
film in addition to benedict cumberbatch
as dr steven strange elizabeth olsen
will of course also be back as wander
maximoff or now called scarlet witch at
doctor strange's side will once again be
his faithful companion wong he will
continue to be played by benedict wong a
fellow companion from the first film of
2016 will also be back mandy's chew till
eg4 in the role of karl mordo
the latter turned his back on the order
of sorceress at the end of the first
part after strange and others partially
broke their own laws it remains
therefore exciting whether mortal finds
his way back into the mcu as a friend or
a foe also returning is dr christine
palmer played by rachel mcadams palmer
was not only a colleague but also the
girlfriend of strange and often got him
off the hook in the first part
a previously unknown hero will
definitely be newly integrated into the
franchise namely none other than
american chavez also known as miss
america the young heroine is played by
social comments who's best known for the
netflix series the babysitter's club
miss america is one of the few lgbtq
characters known so far in the marvel
universe in addition to her superhuman
strength she can also tear star-shaped
gaps in reality that allow her to move
within the multiverse in the comics she
comes from a parallel world that exists
outside of time and space of the marvel
multiverse as this world is threatened
by black holes chavez's mother
sacrifices herself to send her through
an interdimensional void to earth where
she now lives as the last of her kind
whether the character will be adapted
one to one from the comics we do not
know at this point in time
unfortunately so far nothing more has
been confirmed we are also eagerly
awaiting a real villain nevertheless
there are plenty of rumors about the
rest of the cast in the post-credits
scene of one division you can hear her
sons billy and tommy calling for her one
more time hence it is not ruled out that
we will get to see jed klein and julian
hillard on the big screen where would it
be more appropriate than in a movie
about multiple universes according to
the british newspaper someone said live
the two have even been seen on set
residents around the filming location
confirmed this claim as well another
name that keeps popping up in the rumor
mill is adam hugo he is supposed to play
the extraterrestrial minotaur intro who
likewise possesses magical abilities and
is an ally of doctor strange in the
comics meanwhile one actor who is rather
thrown his own name into the fray is
trash film legend bruce campbell the
latter tweeted a photo from london
revealing that he was working with a
certain director on a certain film
during the same time the shooting of
doctor strange ii was taking place in
the british capital city besides he has
been very close friends with director
sam raimi for a long time thus we can be
intrigued to see whether we can admire
the man with a chainsaw in the mcu as
well
since there is no official trailer yet
we can only refer to rumors that have
been leaked in the past few months these
say that steven strange will start
researching more about time travel and
other multiverses after end game yet an
old friend has been drawn to evil trying
to stop stranger studies and leading him
to summon indescribable evil this evil
could be the villain nightmare as he's a
recurring opponent of strange in the
comics and also travels through
different dimensions for this purpose a
name which is heard just as often when
it comes to villains is mephisto he was
already considered as the main
antagonist in one division yet he was
still replaced both would fit great into
the storyline and it seems more than
feasible that it will be one of the two
also when it comes to who's the friend
who opposes our hero finding names isn't
too hard of course after all with mordo
we have someone who already turned his
back on him in the first part the rumors
however rather point to wanda as scarlet
witch she could be guided by dark forces
in the meantime after all
as seen in the post-credits scene she
studies a spellbook called darkhold
which is full of black magic
indeed in one division agatha harkness
has already hinted that the scarlet
witch will destroy the world so it could
be that she lets the multiverse collapse
and several realities blur into each
other using the power of the darkhold
this would also coincide with spiderman
no way home in this one villain from
many different realities appear such as
alfred molina as dr octopus our sorcerer
supreme would then have to fix wander's
mistake and simultaneously fight against
villains from other dimensions also
clears that the movie will have a touch
of horror after all director sam raimi
is best known for his horror films
obviously the events related to
multiverse of madness will have an
influence on many events in the mcu not
only spider-man but also the loki series
is said to have been heavily inspired by
these actions naturally we won't know to
what extent until next year the
protagonists in ant-man and the wasp
quantomania definitely suffer from the
fact that reality is emerging so while
too many heroes have to deal with gang
the conqueror we were already able to
meet him at the end of loki albeit as a
friendly version of himself thus the
next one who enters the world of our
heroes will be a lot more evil
incidentally kang is not only supposed
to be the villain for ant-man but once
again he will be the antagonist for
heroes across several films according to
rumors the effects of the events are
even to have a direct influence on the
upcoming fantastic four these are really
just rumors though since even the
planning revolving around the film is
still in its early stages
so that was our preview of doctor
strange in the multiverse of madness
what are your thoughts who will be the
next villain we will see on screen and
most importantly who will betray strange
let us know in the comments we can
barely contain ourselves with
anticipation to see who will be arriving
from all the different realities as soon
as the trailer is out we will finally
know more you will be able to watch it
either on our youtube channel or
directly on our website
kinochak.com see you next time
[Music]
you